let's go to roman from pittsburgh roman
welcome
hey david how are you good good i have
to ask
are you ukrainian or russian by chance
um you know it's funny i moved to
cleveland and uh there's a lot of
eastern europeans around this part um
i'm actually i'm italian wow there's a
sandwich yeah
you know what's so funny about i've
never you would
there's lots of people who are not
familiar with the name roman
and when you tell them my name is roman
they go that must be because you're
italian and i've never met anyone with
that name who's actually italian they're
always russian or ukrainian but you
actually are italian and your name is
roman
yeah ironically it's uh it was my
parents favorite chapter in the bible
but i just there's a there's a sandwich
shop around here that makes a roman
burger so i joke that you know they just
were hungry when they were pregnant my
mom was pregnant so fair enough all
right well what's on your mind today
um
i just wanted to comment i'm an
ultrasound tech or a sonographer
depending on how fancy you want to be
okay and um
you know i have a lot of history
scanning
early pregnancies so um seeing all these
bills pass it's very frustrating to see
these people who obviously have no
medical background trying to
you know make any assessment on you know
roe v wade or anything like that it's
it's very frustrating um most of the
people i do ultrasounds with have no
idea that they're pregnant so um yeah
and i think i think this is interesting
there's two there's two sides to this
right one side of it is you often will
have a panel of like eight
seventy-year-old
men
saying we decide what's legal and
abortion and all this you know obg kob
care and all this different stuff that
makes absolutely no sense
also
i think
sometimes when we take this too far we
get into the stuff where like during the
iraq war you had a lot of right wingers
going if you haven't been in the
military
you can't have an opinion about this war
and it's like no you can actually
actually you can so i think we want to
balance both sides of the this but your
point is very well taken
yeah um it's uh it's just one of those
things where
um
the
uh medicine is like you know really
messy and like i think uh like even joe
rogan when he talks about it he's like
oh i'm pro-life
or sorry pro-choice but he's like it
kind of gets really messy when you talk
about like late-term abortions and i
think that people really get mired in
those details and like 80 percent of
abortions occur like less before 12
weeks yeah um like a quarter of
pregnancies and before people even
realize that they're pregnant so it i
feel like there's a lot of
misunderstandings of when abortions
happen and like why they happen um like
like just look i mean i'm not going to
tell people to look up some of these
complex medical things but like
hydrocephalus like some like it's not a
viable thing like i don't think that it
makes sense to make someone carry a baby
that doesn't have a brain to full term
but i mean what are you going to do
one of the other things that's often
mentioned in this discussion is the
right wingers will say
you know you it's crazy that you can
walk in at eight and a half months
pregnant and say abort and when you
actually talk to ob gyns they almost
universally say number one never happens
once you're eight and a half if if
you're if you're given a due date at 40
weeks and it's two weeks before that and
you walk in and you go i'd like to abort
first of all ob gyn say it never happens
number two they almost exclusively say i
also wouldn't do it at that point you go
wait a second yeah there's no medical
condition threatening your life no well
so why why would we do that let's talk
about adoption let's
obgyn say that's an imaginary situation
yeah i mean even at like 24 weeks you
can at least like
you know stabilize a pregnancy but like
before that i mean like it's it's not
even a conversation um hey real quick
i'm curious because you so you're in a
situation where you're doing the
ultrasounds for women who they may not
even know they're pregnant so why are
they getting an ultrasound if they don't
do what's the circumstance of them
getting an ultrasound
yeah so i mean we do a lot of different
ultrasounds
what they call a general ultrasound tech
there are like other ultrasound techs
who uh specialize in only doing ob um
personally like the late term stuff is
it gets uh i feel bad a lot of times for
those those people who only work in mfm
because a lot of times they are scanning
women who either have you know they're
at risk for some reason because that you
know they're most likely to come back
for like follow-up stance scans so
that's um
uh uh maternal diabetes slash obesity
um
drug use
um twins makes you automatically at risk
some sort of um prior history of of
complication
for me it's um they come in through the
er and then they have some sort of
indication either pain
bleeding
um
they they came in with a positive
pregnancy test and
they had some sort of uh prior
ultrasound and uh some you know
sometimes they come in to like get a
follow-up i don't recommend that coming
in through the er
especially if you're coming in from a
different hospital system we won't have
that history sure um and you know it's
very rare that this happens but just you
know want to put this out there do not
come to try to get pictures if you're
coming in through the er
um we we can't let you take pictures of
the screen it's like a legal issue and
like we don't have a printer because
we're not right designed to do these now
because you're a tech you're not
delivering the news oh hey you're
pregnant right you're doing the scanning
and then a doctor says hey this shows
that you're pregnant
yeah um we we write um
like a short little uh
a set like they call it like a tech
assessment yep and then um the
radiologist can either agree or disagree
with our assessment um i yeah i keep my
mouth shut and personally i kind of like
that um the liability is not something i
want um and like i only needed you know
two school two years of schooling the
ten years and a hundred thousand dollars
worth it that just does not seem worth
it you know i gotcha i gotcha all right
well listen i appreciate you uh sharing
about this super interesting
can i ask you a really quick question
yeah go ahead
um do you think it's good for democrats
if ron desantis runs um too early to say
depends who he's running against i know
i know the point of the question which
is like is he any is he a better or more
difficult candidate to defeat i just
think we don't know until we know who
the democratic nominee is
yeah i thought maybe if he ran against
trump that it might cause like almost a
slip split ticket like a ball oh in the
primary that's another question yeah
it's just too early to say
all right thank you very much all right
thank you so much appreciate the call
very very interesting i have to tell you